someone tell me where this 479 dollars
and fifty seven cents of whatever
denomination comes from no no it's this
is fine i want someone else to help me
yeah so if you can get the original
amount and you divide it by 100 and then
each times the answer for an exam ok
this is this is what you're suggesting
that I do yes ok No someone help me up
what's that about Oh 23 and then you get
into a brace see the thing is slippery
perfect I agree degrees yeah people are
great yes what did what do you think x 5
a 97 for night this original number yes
so what you're suggesting yeah ok all
right what is this slightly different to
you get 480 and any singing off that ok
hmm ok I'm very interesting very very
easter because because um these two
things they're clearly in the same
ballpark so our common sense check is
going to fail us here because both of
them could be right but which one is it
which one is the real Emma I didn't do
for a system yet yeah go ahead I missing
I had which now what number did you
start with weight 108
x up x 3 x 3 because it you'll get that
amount yep have the former 94.1 and then
take away that mouth so you're saying do
that and subtract it from this is that
what you're saying what I recommend
changes my uniform 94.4 yeah 597 over a
hundred this was the same ones or
disclose it the uterus is nicer person
is that not exactly the services I'm
sorry let me rephrase that's exactly the
same thing as that is that yeah see you
soon I think once because it's three
percent weight rise
sorry feel good cut you off mid-sentence
so you go if she received the three
percent edgewise that's three slip on
the original now that we're trying to
find out not very percent on this but
you can do it if you do it the way they
everyone's been doing here through that
you end up having to round it up to
almost the right answer ok so we're
obviously all right now akhil sense i'll
be very very helpful here on yes because
you know with how do we sort out which
one is which right which which approach
do we take oh by the way having this
book have you thought right now I think
you're doing more maths right now than
any of you were when you actually did
your answer right like can you convince
yourself no this one's right because or
this one's wrong because just now the
thing I think I guess I'm just so
helpful is understanding what this three
percent is which is another way of
saying what does that three percent of
52 so let's rewind a little bit Julie
had some weekly wage pretty good
apparently ok she had a weekly wage it
went up to this the the reason it went
up is because of some amount and she got
a three percent right right so is some
number now here's something right when
you have a number and you don't know
what it is we have a whole branch of
mathematics dedicated to when you don't
know what these numbers aren't we call
algebra right so let me just say let's
call her our weekly wage w fur wedge
okay so that wage i have to multiply it
by something to make it bigger write a
three percent bigger and that'll give me
her new weekly wage does that make sense
okay so what I x 103 percent or 1.03
they'll be the same thing right so her
old weekly wage it gets bigger by three
percent and what does it equal to after
that happens or not that number right
okay now that you've written this I hope
this shows you which answer is right and
why what are we trying to fight we're
trying to find w her wage before the
increase so what do i do to both sides
here
I survived through I mean okay or 1.03
okay now this is so interesting right
because it's a small number because
three percent rate is pretty close
actually to like what you're doing if
you're doing it in reverse you end up
with answers that are quite close to
each other okay but what this question
is assessing is like a kill mention
right do you really understand this and
what it applies to write the numbers are
not hard right actually punching this
into your calculator that's the easy
part 103 but knowing what to put where
that's the hard part right and we all
disagree so glad we thought about that
ever makes sense right I don't know if
any of you wrote down this lime I
wouldn't be surprised if you didn't
that's okay but I hope you can see why
me writing this line sort of settles it
okay this makes sense of the question so
that's why I can use it otherwise we've
all just sort of I've been back and
forth with no reasoning behind it how
come it's so close because because the
difference between our this answer and
this sounds up is is the three percent
about what you had before right I three
percent of what what is the opposite is
this number right yeah three percent of
this number right or when you do this
thing this ninety-seven percent what
you're now working at is three percent
of this number I can't now look for 90
forty cents for 80 it pretty close and
three percent is a small amount right so
when you take a small amount of numbers
that are pretty close that's why these
end up being very similar to each other
okay yeah yeah all right are we happier
about the second questions yeah yeah ok
so maybe guy are you were right the
first place the first one is should we
have a look at it let's have a look um
$25,000 vintage car after two years it
increases in value by eight percent and
then decrease in value by episode five
percent rather because I don't know they
left the EU is
okay now therefore what calculation
comes before we get this number can I
just confirm what did you actually put
into your captor 1.8 times one point or
eight times the 25,000 so that's going
to be the first year and then what do I
do with that okay so then the second
year because it decreases in value i'm
going to i can do this on one here right
if i lose 5% what percentage is left
over it's like this isn't it it's like
this right I'll only be left with
ninety-five percent so I could do that i
can do all in one here and that should
give me that yes I can't i calculate the
overall percentage change in value do
you not have a good reason it just it's
to 256 so did somebody forget the final
value yep minus your original value
which is 250 okay pause what Sandy's
right what does this tell us like this
isn't the final answer this is this is
the difference so this is the change and
then I want to work out from that
percentage change right okay it's an
idiotic it going to divide it no I
directed it by what am i buying by the
original value so much okay very good so
what you're doing here right is you're
comparing the change that's the
numerator with whatever you started from
and that'll give you two point six so
they give you two for ticks they don't
okay